[Musik]
marco koch die bekannteste polizist der
deutschschweiz verlässt die bühne als
medienchef der stadtpolizei war
omnipräsent auf allen kanälen
er hatte sie bereits ist klagte ihn
beruhigt
sowieso hat sich laut gesetz verschärft
herr cortese gibt's denn die bilderfolge
woche kommen
populär und weil entscheidend aber nicht
unumstritten
trotzdem muss man sagen medien stellen
das ist nicht der fanclub von der
stadtpolizei energie wachse oder medina
die konfrontationen blieben
einsatzmittel und taktiken besser
der respekt vor der polizei nahmen
unterdessen hat sich gehalt durch ein
positiver der polizei er im moment ist
das erkläre mir stellen vorher meine
reifen bevor man darüber machen
ein leben im dienst der polizei
[Musik]
interview termin an der langstrasse es
geht um eine krone kontrolle über die
verspätet berichtet wurde
mangelnde transparenz so der vorwurf die
rundschau fragte nach wie es probiert
aber das ist ja grundsätzlich ist
natürlich so die polizei
aber mit einem fehler offen transparent
und schnell kommunizieren
das ist ein politischer polizei
verständlich der auftrag transparent und
offen kommunizieren unabhängig davon
dass politik will oder nicht
die stadtpolizei zürich rasch offen und
transparent kommunizieren das haben wir
wieder im fall weil aber die
zuständigkeit ein wirklich zum 30 eine
botschaft mehrfach wiederholt cortesi
ganz der profi ließ sich auch durch
zwischenrufe nicht aus der ruhe bringen
lässt
dementsprechend sei nicht politisch
aktiv
der langsamste andere quartiere die sich
jetzt metro damit eine ganze reihe in
der langstraße muss ich glaube das ist
richtig so wenn ich die frage sie haben
stets fällig werden
und sie sind sicher auch noch so hoch
wie im hintergrund das fernsehen auch
noch ein neues bild von der polizei auf
der straße im kreis 4 sehen die das bild
noch unbedingt
mehrfach musste marco cortesi schon
angegriffen
natürliche der letzten jahres nahmen den
namen spiels gehört wohl nicht
ausstrahlen vermögen wir gerade das
politische streifen politisch sitze
sowie mini kollege der lettischen
meister hier taucht ihr aber auch
erstmals ein phänomen auf das die
polizei bis heute beschäftigt die
beamten angepöbelt und angegriffen die
stadtpolizei versuchte 2009 die alte
ordnung wieder herzustellen wie der
respekt verschaffen null toleranz so
streifen das werk geplant auf der
landstraße komplett ab juli auf der
busspur verbotenerweise ein wegen fahrer
entgegen er doziert das polizeiauto und
kraft getreten
auf jeden fall gibt es kein pardon
aus der verkehrstoten polizeilichen
großeinsatz
keine angenehme aufgabe diesen vorfall
zu erklären
muss das ist das was wir werden mit der
aktion beispiel ja das ist natürlich an
und für sich kleinlich aber die ganze
polizei arbeit beruht natürlich auf dem
das ein reh beträge gegenseitig
respektieren und die regler sind ganz
klar
und das ist mittellos ist einfach der
autoren gelernt mehr akzeptieren dass
mit polizisten aus bayern star am
plateau der angriffe und aufgrund von
dem schaffen man einfach david speck
gebilde gaben zu reden
heute ist klar die aktion waren flüge
aber halt wort respekt ist schon mal
falsche und nachher ist natürlich die
ganze aktion durch das den ins stocken
geraten
ich glaube mir hätte vielleicht eine
andere weniger
zum glück ja der dialog noch möglich
gesucht dass man miteinander redet und
ich glaube das ist der richtige weg
marco cortesi wurde das gesicht dieses
neuen stils
[Musik]
arbeitsbeginn vor 7 uhr in der urania
wache
es war routine mit den crooner läuft
wenig in marco cortesi letzten
arbeitstagen vor der pensionierung im
schnitt beantwortet die medienstelle
sonst 25.000 telefonanruf im jahr mit
einem vierköpfigen team der chef legt
wert auf harmonie und den gleichen
wichtiger die von gern das glück
polizeiausbildung der sauber die kripo
mannschaften dasselbe genau wissen wie
eine verhaften konnte sie aber wissen
wir mit polizei jahren bin ich dass man
danach die entsteht und akzeptanz
innerhalb von der polizei ist natürlich
sicher größer
vom prüfer und das team konnte sich eine
eingeschworene truppe wohl die
schwierigste wir sprechen die jungen
keine titels sei die jeden tag stellt
sich die frage welche neuen fälle eine
pressemitteilung verdienen
das auto im feld entdeckt wurde
der abstand war mit dem tisch und es
dennoch schwer verletzt wenn man auch
vom spital hat dank eines speziellen
fall der mann rief jetzt ist sehr
speziell frauen immer geschafft und ich
will dass man die teile dann das geld
und worauf machten sich die
zwischenzeiten aufs wc sie wiederholt
die kunden sehr komisch und bitter und
hat dann der verdacht dass der kollege
gegenüber sie dass man drinnen
dauerregens und gestorben so kräftig
sind aber in diesem unseren kann aber
die hand die man darin die
selbstverständlich sichergestellt
ja
es wird sich zeigen die mandarine war
nicht vergiftet von skurril bis tragisch
marco modi sie hat alles erlebt
1994 helikopter unglück im triemli
quartier wieder aus bewohnern auch
passanten relegation aber der heli pilot
und der einzige passagier wurden getötet
in ersten großen einsatz marco velo
tisch und was für die fluggesellschaft
der heirat hätten was der helikopter
dort müsse man nicht die unfallursache
ist im moment an klar wir sind am warten
aufs büro für flug noch gekriegt sie ja
weil ich das werde ich natürlich
zufrieden im innen mitarbeiter in mir
selber tun sich ganz klar spürbar selbst
mal dass sie nicht am seeufer mikrofon
kh das geht natürlich eine solide
blockade des ktbl medien druck das ist
natürlich ganz anders denn note 4 kann
wäre geld oft sind um die vierte vor
sagt sie zweigt eine straße wagen
entgleist verletzte
nach ersten informationen soll es mehr
als 20 personen über verletzt sind und
jetzt schalte zum uns schnell man wo vor
ort ist offenbar ein interviewpartner
bissig
die offizielle zahl was kann man sagen
zu verletzten oder eventuell sogar zwei
tote was sollte
bemerkt sie sich im moment ist ziemlich
sauer auf
natürlich schön also das ist raus
die gibt es immer und auch der herr
schnell machen ist erfahren sie drehen
kann ich mein name richtig der
problemlosen schwere braucht dieses land
unterschiedlich alkohol oder egal egal
wie lüd einfach nico und ich glaube drei
vernünftige reagierte bin ich gar nicht
großzügiger durch die rede nach einer
sehr wahrscheinlich wahnsinnig in dem
moment natürlich schade aufgeregt ist
der eigene zionistischen vergessen
bilder der zerstörung mit der zeit wird
klar die flanken fahrt forderte ein
todesopfer und 45 verletzt
die machen ist also immer ich will ich
will dass sich viele an die emotionen
die betroffenheit und das sage ich immer
meine mitarbeitenden ganz ganz schlimm
ist wenn ihr noch erinnern wie
öffentlich auftreten
das ist nichts gegen ein dass er eine
solche erlebnisse müssen privat
ausbalanciert sein
seit 25 jahren ist sie an marco cortesi
seite bringt kühle
geschäftsleitungsmitglied in einem
architektur unternehmen
sie teilt gott das ist liebe zu seiner
heimat dem engadin
gemeinsam haben sie den piz palü
bestiegen das video hat es selber
geschnitten
[Musik]
ihm zuliebe hat die zürcherin sogar
rätoromanisch gelernt die augen habe und
ich sehr gerne hand und zimmerkollegen
er war es endlich mal das wort frage
warum heißt es überhaupt so und das hat
der bündnerin zürich wartet dialekt eine
karriere booster hat er spielt sich
bushido das ist das gehört einfach zum
gesamtpaket dass ihre räder mit mit
allem drum und dran
ich bin die person und ich bin und wir
werden ihn andere könne sie und ich bin
froh hanne der dialekt wenn ich jetzt
vor hohlwelle teams geprägte was nicht
das denn nur die richtige mischung war
das kürzel debatte zum das gehört zum
paket vermutlich lieber wenig anzieht
wie 60 oder so die in der stadt paris
anna der kleine marco 1956 in salaten
geboren sein älterer bruder
schwerbehindert stellen markus vater
arbeitet in tiefbauamt leitende position
mit portmonee weg sie mit blenden mit
der luftrettung vögel james gravierend
nützlich cortesi als 16-jähriger zum
post mehr gemacht und dennoch eine
freundin schlägt vor ich solle doch zur
polizei
und tatsächlich mit den 28
die polizeischule an
unternehmen vorstellen wenn wir
normalform zeigen aber der speziellen
der kämpfe ich hoch setzt sich
beharrlich gegen widersacher durch wird
als polizei-sprecher zum medienstar
also wenn ich jetzt mehr zeit für mich
nicht trennen was sie da nicht gern
die wähler können erfülle ich bin
zufrieden mit dem nichts rüber und ich
muss sagen ich habe sehr viel glück ich
bin immer der mensch in einer karte wo
es gut mit mir meint dann ist das super
gemacht hast du
[Musik]
auf einen fall ist marco cortesi
besonders stolz am tag nach dem zürcher
millionen kunstraub hier die bührle
sammlung läuft fahren die gewichtungen
die nachricht geht um die welt in einem
filmreifen kreisen räuber im bibelmuseum
vier bilder von der wand einen schritt
nach links im parterre sind die wir
glaubte bindung an der wand kamen sich
trotz nur mit bewegungsmelder bisherigen
kleine süße mal dass die drei maskierten
bewaffneten rumänien sind es personal
zwingen sich am boden lag
zweifel des internets nur frank steier
und hannes bild noch an andere denken es
ist der größte kunstraub und der
geschichte europas
man muss davon ausgehen dass die leute
ganz genau gewusst haben was sie wollen
zwei millionen einwohner für 20
millionen kastanienweg von frank 55
millionen
mit der wächter vom saison für 100
millionen schweizer franken
heute sind alle kunstwerke zurück an
einem diebstahl sicheren ort
der direktor der sammlung bührle lucas
luhr hat uns in ein schwergewicht das
lager geführt
irgendwo im raum zürich er glaubt dass
wirklich die fahndung beginnt holtwick
obwohl klar ist wie das thema auto
aussieht
während er mal einen radius von zwei
kilometer um das prima gemacht und kennt
alle polizistinnen und polizisten aus
geschickt nach einem gewissen alter
daten und inhalte und dann hat es
tatsächlich europa geht er hat sehr gute
angezogen hat nur über eine wiese oder
butt nie gelobt und das ist natürlich
wirklich ein flop muss man fehler und
das ist nicht stadtpolizei zürich
so vergeht eine woche bis hainburg als
die zwei der gestohlenen bilder gefunden
werden
text bildern gestellte wo regelmäßig die
gemütliche bord kontrolliert
wir dürfen wollen aber nicht vergessen
dass zwei weitere bilder unserer
sammlung weiterhin viel ab circa 16 uhr
stehen ihnen auch medienmitteilungen in
englischer und französischer sprache auf
unsere homepage zur verfügung
marco cortesi im zentrum der
aufmerksamkeit aber die ermittlungen
noch viele jahre dauern
2012 dieser bilde für die serbische
polizei dank unterstützung aus zürich
schnappt die falle zu
der millionenschwere knabe mit der roten
weste hat das abenteuer bestanden
stadtpolizei zürich sondern für polizei
schlechthin mehr oder weniger in ganz
europa dar auf der welt sich der größten
forum rhein keine hd-bilder wieder im
werk und der bedarf wirklich mit
mutmasslichen sondern die sind eher
verurteilt worden hat keine dingfest
machen und alle sich stellen und dem
schlussstein die bilder wieder da bald
haben die täter ihre haft abgesessen die
ermittler befürchten racheakte ein
wahrer krimi
soviel wieder im fall eines älteren mann
ist heute morgen mit dem auto oder sesam
und schreibt panik doch ganz andere
beziehung zu meinem leben werden die
werke der sammlung bührle werden ab
herbst in diesem erweiterungsbau des
kunsthauses zu sehen sein
der kunstraub ein jahrhundert fall
wiederkehrend dagegen die querelen um
den ersten mai auf die friedliche
demonstration folgten immer wieder
ausschreitungen
diese bilder sind mehr als zehn jahre
alt gold bereitete man standorte und
mitläufer liefert sich im landkreis 14
uhr spiel mit der polizei
flasche liegt containerbrand es gibt
ausnahmen
eine starke sind polizistinnen und
polizisten angriffen wurde und dann
würde ich vereins wunder dass die
schwere verletzung auskuriert hat
für mich ist nicht nachvollziehbar
das ist unglaublich was da abgegangen
ist jäh zerstört worden dass da was die
randalierer seien könne man muss halt
polizei inzwischen ganz andere taktische
mittel es als mittel mich an filmsets
stören und lenker der schein trügt und
fazit trekkies ich genau wo ist jetzt
leiter der krimis ruhm genau wo blüht
platziert sind wo dato stand und der
hand durch das natürlich viel viel
schneller verschiebe gefrorene herz war
zuvor gemacht hat mit mit mit magnet li
und dementsprechend ist das nicht
möglich was vor zehn jahren ermöglicht
sich einkesseln und abwürgen die taktik
heute
auch das thema waffen beschäftigt
cortesi immer wieder groß das interesse
der medien stellen
stromae eigentliche software ganz mit
der fünfsitzige schusswaffen als meister
stand ist stadtführer aber natürlich
immer mehr in letzter zeit auch mit ganz
gewöhnlichen wir jetzt zum beispiel
darauf eine pump action und in letzter
zeit leider auch immer wieder verdeckt
die waffe verdeckt und dann treibt
weiter wird zum beispiel der grünen
revolution lichtstrom eine gürtellinie
wir besuchen die waffensammlung der
stadtpolizei wir werden beschlagnahmte
und vereinzelt neu gekaufte waffen
aufbewahrt für schulungszwecke und
ballistische abklärungen
klar ist der waffengebrauch hat sich
verändert was man sich an seine ist das
natürlich deutlich sie liegt mit
schusswaffen sie ein extrem abgenommen
früher bin ich ein bonus gerückt das
sind 45 am boden lag mit menschen und
unterstützt das nach ungarn immer vor
dass der schuss war vernichtend mit
stichwaffen wir viel viel stichwahl von
damit gravierende verletzungen
auch die messe bietet geordnet und
gekostet das immer als einziges
kriterium automatischen als kriterium
journalist der hochleistungs wieder hört
für lotte mit dem mit dem bügel
konkret war marco cortesi bemüht die
fachgebiete seiner kollegen ins beste
licht zu rücken so wenn man eigentlich
machen wir natürlich größe ist aber mit
dem auge viel besser erkennen also wenn
ihr biss kann zahlen gesichertes
stahlstangen untersucht und wenn ich
jetzt einen poller stahlhandel nicht das
ganze bild anders als wenn ich das
einfach so sehr um mit der imitation
waffen
das kann ich also zeigen egal ob prinzip
der unterschied zeigen dass man immer
das kann einfach niemand ich probiere
mit der luther bis zu zeigen
zu jeder eu sarges bild zu machen und
dann haben wir wirklich verstorben und
waschen 3d scanner oder virtuelle
ausbildung und dies bringt die
stadtpolizei immer wieder in die medien
das ist wahnsinnig faszinierend sind ja
immer auf dem neuesten stand wären die
meisten minister mit diese begeisterung
für alle polizei belange stößt marco
cortesi allerdings auch auf ablehnung
marco cortesi ton 1 media sprache statt
polizist mit leib und seele war der
richtige verein vor der stadtpolizei
mitarbeitende
das natürlich verständlich zugute halten
muss man sagen der medien stellen das
ist nicht der feind club 55 uhr der
abteilung und dem erhalt magisch
nüchterne sachliche rioler faktor
bezogene kommunikation gewinn
auch die polizei war nicht immer
zufrieden mit ihm das zwar seine
ehemalige politische vorgesetzte
hessische häufiger unter druck sie vom
boot und gotthardt kuehl warum hat das
so gesagt warum hast du dir kritik
größere diskotheken einer konkreten und
das hat ausgesprochen nicht gemacht
bayerische in ihrem büro gestanden
sonntag seien es auch aber sie zahlt man
sagen dass auch haben es nicht machen
und weiter kritisch sie und ich
vermeiden sie dann unter druck du bist
mein name gewachsen
ein mädchen diva und hat mit
das wort sie war ist natürlich als das
fühle ich mich eigentlich nicht
die weiß eigentlich endet die wohl
schneller mal beleidigt ist für mich für
den familienbegriff das mini nicht
gesehen tatsache ist gott das hat sich
über die jahre einen spielraum
erarbeitet wie kein anderer
berufskollege hat und tatsache ist marco
cortesi scheut das rampenlicht nicht ob
spontan auftritt im zirkus oder einsatz
für eine bühnenproduktion der medienchef
der stadtpolizei fühlt sich unter den
leuten sichtlich wohl selbst als
schauspieler dritte auf
[Musik]
am set des deutschen krimis borchert
überwacht die sie den statisten einsatz
der stadtpolizei mit der schauspielerei
ist es vorbei trotz regen nachfrage der
spielerinnen rollstuhl und verletzte
sich nach einem eigenen eine rolle
gespielt und dann hätte ich einen
solchen grounding eine spielern dann als
kommender mann für ein gespräch oder du
bist ja spiel und das ist ja richtig so
hier sieht es marco cortesi auch als
seine aufgabe seele in chemie zufrieden
was absperrband zb ist falsch gespannt
[Musik]
original polizeischule überzieht für die
schauspieler
keiner
denn
[Musik]
sie tagt ab und zu nur die polizisten
stehen in ihrer freizeit im einsatz und
in eine statisten gage marco cortesi
zufrieden alles hat seine richtigkeit
privat interessieren in krimis
allerdings nicht sagt er
sein berufsalltag bringt genug spannung
2007 brand im zunfthaus zur zimmerleuten
sie werde kurz nach dem alarm mit einer
großen geboten 114 satz vier retter
brasilien
die stadt sorgt dass die flammen bereits
meterhoch aus dem dach holen was wir zu
dem zeitpunkt noch nie beim sturz vom
dachstock kunst zum der verhängnisvollen
unfall 40-jährige für wärme wo im
dritten stock versuchs löschen
mit verdacht auf profit aus einer offen
brandplatz stirbt schwierige nacht im
november schließlich extrem kalt dann
hättest du hast doch sicher mit einer
rede
bis dann fällt ihr das kann ich schon an
henrys im rüde dem mega messbereich
tropfen und sind die 5 2 1 geführt weil
man damit dass sich drei jungen
gestanden und der nicht merkt dass mir
die richtige wort hält dass ich das
nicht kann kann
damit müssten sich jetzt den zeiger
marco cortesi verein mal sprachlos
unzählige erinnerungen verbindet ihn mit
der stadt zürich
wenn der januar ist schluss den
chefposten wird seine langjährige
stellvertreterin judith hödl übernehmen
letzten juli hatte sie einen großen
auftritt ihm zu als ein tiger eine
tierpflegerin tätig attackiert
es wird in befragungen stattfinden dann
spuren sich um stadt aber im moment
wissen wir noch nicht mehr bis 300
personen
es ist mir klar es sind große fußstapfen
wo er da hingelangt
aber ich bin anders spielen schon mal
fertig völlig besonders hat
medienchef frau immer meint eine knappe
wie denn das hund aber ich danke ich bin
was schlecht ist ramponiert über
kopieren will dass das ist mir gut
marco cortesi will als
kommunikationsberater im geschäft
bleiben und doxite seine pensionierung
nicht ganz entspannt entgegen
also muss leibovitz ich sich sehr
verändert das ist mir bewusst und das
war eigentlich schon seit längerer zeit
der bedeutungsverlust der kürzlich
geradezu der liste aber ich werde noch
vor dem markt cortesi
es wird sich einiges im ihnen lieber
sich ändern
mehr engadin ist sicher ein ziel mehr
biken weniger termine aber für alle ist
cordes ohne polizei und die polizei ohne
cortesi zurzeit noch schwer vorstellbar
[Musik]